i want to give you a really good simple
inexpensive tip
to increase hair growth
as well as increase the thickness of
your hair now to be totally transparent
i do sell several hair growth products
but in this video i'm not going to
promote that i'm going to give you
a really simple tip and it's very
inexpensive okay
jello that's right jello
now what does jello made of gelatin okay
and then there's another form of gelatin
called hydrolyze collagen so any one of
these three will work now as far as
jello goes i'm not talking about
sweetened jello with artificial
flavoring i'm talking about like the
unflavored i think it's called nox
gelatin so you can get in a powder where
you can dissolve it with water or get it
in you know tablets or just make jello
so there's some interesting things about
gelatin i want to discuss it's first of
all it's 99
protein and it's broken down protein
into
the basic building blocks amino acids
and some peptides now what's a peptide
peptide is a small chain of amino acids
okay so you take this amino acid you
string them together if i'm not mistaken
it could be anywhere between like 2 and
15
amino acids connected together but don't
quote me but gelatin has some
interesting effects not just giving your
hair your skin your nails more protein
but it also increases blood flow
in blood volume okay thereby increasing
blood flow to the little hairs in your
scalp and as far as peptides in this
gelatin there's one called
hydroxyproline
which is
been shown to actually increase hair
growth by itself and you've probably
seen it in a lot of different hair
products
all right
interesting studies i'll put them down
below a lot of these studies are
double-blinded placebo-controlled
clinical trials
between the years 1983 and 1998
but i did not search for studies
recently but some of these studies
showed a 50 increase in hair growth
substantial increase in diameter of your
hair making it thicker as well as
increasing the numbers of hair that are
growing on your head so that's
significant
for three different conditions subreddit
alopecia we have androgenetic alopecia
okay which is a another form of um hair
loss as well as another common condition
called telogen effluvium now in this
video i'm not going to get in the
specifics of each one of these
but apparently gelatin just gives you
the raw material and also the blood flow
to help
add some help to this problem even if
there's an autoimmune component to this
even if there's a genetic weakness to
this problem now as far as the amount i
would recommend i would recommend
between 10 and 14 grams per day that's
like one tablespoon if you're going to
use the powder and in some of the
studies that i'm going to list down
below they didn't just use gelatin they
also added with it l-cysteine okay you
can also get l-cysteine in another
product called nac
and they added some salt pulmetal which
is also good for the hormone
component part of hair loss so anyway i
wanted to keep this video short and just
give you a simple tip and if you haven't
seen my more comprehensive video on hair
loss i put it up right here check it out